with the latest installments into the
Transformers film franchise there has
been one major Decepticon missing though
fans are aching to see Megatron in
action again there's a very good reason
why he doesn't show up in Rise of the
beasts warning spoilers ahead the future
of the live-action Transformers
franchise is set in the past building
off what came in 2018's Bumblebee which
took place in the 1980s Transformers
rise of the Beast shows audiences with
the Autobots threw up to in 1994. in
addition to Sonic the Hedgehog
references and plenty of early 90s
hip-hop the film sees the Autobots team
up with both humans and maximals to take
on a new threat namely Scourge working
on behalf of Unicron to bring the planet
heater to Earth let them come
Unicron Scourge and the other terracons
make for perfectly terrifying villains
but it's only natural for fans to wonder
where megatronus seeing how he's one of
the most powerful Transformers he's been
a villainous staple of the Transformers
franchise from the very beginning and
the primary threat in Michael Bay's
Transformers films he's a Joker to
Optimus Prime's Batman so it makes sense
he gets the Lion's Share of attention in
most adaptations however he's
conspicuously absent during the events
of Rise of the beast but according to
Transformers film continuity his absence
makes complete sense the Transformer's
timeline was pretty tricky to nail down
even when Michael Bay directed them
Bumblebee and Rise of the Beast takes
place in the past but they're still
within the same continuity as those
films that means Megatron can play a
role until the new movies hit 2007. this
is due to a major plot point from the
first Transformers movie in the original
film it's revealed that Megatron has
been on Earth for a long time but he
landed in the Arctic Circle freezing him
for years he was discovered in 1897 and
dugouts in the 1930s by the US
government ways being stored in the
Hoover Dam ever since it's even stated
that scientists use technology found in
Megatron to develop all of the
technology we enjoy today it's not until
2007 that other Decepticons are able to
locate him through the internet they
break into the Hoover Dam and then thaw
him and leave facing a reign of terror
that would continue throughout 2017's
the last night with the two most recent
Transformers movies taking place before
these events the reason Megatron can't
be a menace is that he's still frozen in
ice as a result the filmmakers had to
look toward other antagonists within the
franchise to plague the Autobots to
bring Megatron out before 2007 would be
a major retcon Megatron canonically
being frozen in ice before 2007 has
already caused some problems for the
franchise 2018's bumblebee takes place
in 1987 so Megatron also couldn't factor
into much of that plot instead other
Decepticons namely shatter and dropkick
have to come to Earth to take down
Bumblebee the movie opens with an epic
battle sequence on Cybertron that
includes many of the classic designs of
the likes of Optimus Prime and
Starscream Bumblebee director Travis
Knight initially thought Megatron could
factor into this fight somehow since it
takes place well before 1987 telling The
Hollywood Reporter I had this whole
thing boarded where we see Megatron and
he comes in like Sauron just blowing up
and laying waste to everything the only
problem is that according to the law set
forth by Michael Bay's Transformers
movies Megatron would have already been
frozen on earth when this particular
battle took place he went on to say so
even though I really wanted to see G1
Megatron on the battlefield at the Fall
of Cybertron I couldn't do it it's a bit
of a shame Megatron likely won't appear
in a live-action Transformers movie
until the story catches up to the 21st
century but given the ending to
Transformers rise of the Beast there are
plenty of interesting directions for
these prequels to take
thank you
[Music]